[Musik]
eine sehr eigene Liebeserklärung an den
andalusischen Tanz Flamenco das ist pure
Weiblichkeit doch hier tanzen
ausschließlich Männer
[Musik]
Johannesevangelium
war machten sich alle über mich lustig
ich fühlte dass ich nicht die Rolle
erfüllte die gesellschaftlich von mir
erwartet wurde also habe ich mich in
meinem Zimmer eingeschlossen und dort in
diesem kleinen Zimmer konnte ich meiner
Vorstellung freien Lauf lassen ich
konnte mich verkleiden und nicht so frei
bewegen wie es mir draußen als Mann
verwirrt.
heute geht Manuel
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Manuel Linien erforscht durch den
Flamenco das eigene Selbst und
interpretiert den Tanz immer wieder neu
sowie 2018 in my lady Auto zu Deutsch
Autoren Tanz wie ein Magier zaubert er
Traumwelten auf die Bühne und nimmt das
Publikum auf einer Reise durch sein
Unterbewusstsein weg
dass er immer wieder bewusst mit den
Geschlechterrollen bricht und damit
provoziert bringt ihm Anerkennung beim
Publikum und in den Kritiken
[Musik]
den Anfang für eine Veränderung haben
Manuel Linien und sein Ensemble schon
mutig geschafft